tammy please help me through this how
does one
balance self-love with wanting to
improve or
change in some manner okay well there
has to be
there has to be uh self-love there has
to be self but there has to be love for
the little boy that you were
and all the mistakes that you made there
how there has to be love
for that little boy in order for you
and in order for you to be in the
present and have
the generosity that you need to
let god in because it's a generous
um invitation
you know and and you're not going to
make a generous
invitation if you're not
in a way feeling like you are
the more you can accept who you are and
who you were
and the things that happened to you the
more generous you feel the more you can
let god in
because it's not it's not an on or off
switch
you know you get a little god and then
something else happens to get a little
bit more
and some days it's a little bit less and
it depends on
how accepting you are
how aware you are how accepting you are
and then what action follows
because the action will be different
than it was if you were
guarded and if you were
empty the action you you go
how you move forward is going to be
different than if you're feeling
acceptance aware
aware of the discontent aware of the
discontent and accepting the discontent
and then what action follows for
um reconciliation is going to be
different than if you weren't accepting
and so a way to move forward into a
better place
is the is the awareness and the
acceptance
but the acceptance is the hard part
because it takes
looking back in the past and
and coming to peace with who you've
always been and who
and everybody around you and all the
interactions that you've had and
everything and
being grateful that that has brought to
where you are today
that's that's hard you're giving me a
different perspective
i was recently speaking to someone named
bernardo castro
he's a philosopher and he said to me as
we were talking he said kurt don't take
yourself too seriously and then for me
i'm thinking that i don't take myself
seriously enough i see being ascetic and
austere as
something i should be and even
necessary for moving toward a higher
purpose but then i also see that
right now as i'm speaking to you
maybe that's or plenty of that is me
a distaste for what i currently am in a
dislike for my former self
and that's not easy it's not easy to
accept it's not easy to
confront no it's a process a long
process